if you haven't seen Deadpool but you'd
like what you see from Deadpool to is
amazing marketing campaign and you
should probably go rent Deadpool it's
pretty hilarious but it's not for kids
even though the sequel is only the
second movie in the series it's part of
the long-running
extra confusing x-men franchise making
matters even crazier Deadpool 2 is
bringing in a ton of extra heroes from
the comics if you're planning to see the
Merc with a mouth in action but just
don't have the time for Deadpool or
maybe you just want to know who all
these new people are here's everything
you need to know before seeing Deadpool
2 mr. pool Deadpool is Wade Wilson a
mercenary with a military blackops past
the first shot we see him work is
scaring a nerdy pizza delivery guy out
of stalking the object of his obsession
he uses the money he gets from the gig
for a night of fun with his soon-to-be
main squeeze
Vanessa Wilson and Vanessa spend a wild
year together until Wilson learns he's
dying from cancer with no other options
available Wilson agrees to undergo an
experimental treatment that he's told
will turn him into a superhero he
doesn't learn until later that the
program's patients are actually
super-powered slaves sold off to the
highest bidder the experiments give
Wilson the ability to heal from just
about any wound but they also make his
skin look like Freddy Krueger's on his
off time
Wilson frequents a bar called sister
Margaret's that's patronized mainly by
mercenaries the bars owner weasel hosts
a Deadpool in which the rowdy customers
can bet on who among them will die next
which inspires Wilson's code name
Deadpool staple lube is breaking the
fourth wall he knows he's a fictional
character and he revels in his movie
takes plenty of potshots at other
superhero movies particularly the x-men
series the character played by Ryan
Reynolds also pokes fun at Reynolds
himself through jokes about his
performances in Green Lantern and x-men
origins Wolverine the Cable Guy there
was a time in the 90s when it seemed
like just about every new x-men
character was from some kind of
dystopian alternate future Cable is one
of these Time cross refugees played by
Josh Brolin Cable is Nathan summers the
child of Cyclops and a clone of Jean
Grey who's sent into the future and
returns initially to take over command
of the x-men's Junior
team the New Mutants cables cybernetic
enhancements are due to a lethal
techno-organic virus slowly turning his
body into a machine luckily he's also a
mutant with telepathic and telekinetic
powers which he uses to keep the virus
at bay
that's the cable of the comics but we
don't know how different the cable of
Deadpool 2 will be just that he'll be
from the future he's a cyborg and he's a
formidable warrior we also know that
Cable has come to the present with his
sights on a teenager named Russell for
reasons unknown speaking of whom the new
kid the kid the cables hunting in the
trailers remains shrouded in mystery we
know his name is Russell and that he
seems to have pyrokinetic powers giving
us a solid idea of his comic inspiration
Russell is likely inspired by rusty
Collins aka fire fist first appearing in
the pages of x-factor he's able to
manipulate fire much like pyro from
x-men to what we still don't know is
what cable wants with him does Russell
somehow cause the dark future the cables
from or is this solely a mission of
personal vengeance either way
Deadpool takes up the cause of defending
the kid assembling a new team to take
cable out the luckiest lady
Nina Thurmond aka Domino is the end
result of a government breeding project
designed to produce the perfect killer
Domino is surrounded at all times by a
probability field that affects her and
her enemies try to shoot at Domino and
there's a good chance your gun will Jam
or even explode in your face if Domino
leaps from the top of a tall building
with no plan of survival something is
likely to come along and cushion or stop
her fall much like Deadpool Domino's
relationships with Marvel's other
mutants tend to be somewhat tenuous
unlike the x-men she's no moral crusader
but she'll often work alongside them if
there's an opportunity for fun profit or
both she first appeared in the pages of
the x-men comic x-force making her a
natural fit for the version of the team
assembling in Deadpool 2 pure bedlam
introduced during 1995 s alternate
universe Age of Apocalypse events bedlam
was originally the collective name of
two brothers Jesse and Christopher
Aronson
after that story wrapped up Jesse
Aronson was reintroduced in the pages of
x-force bedlam produces an
electromagnetic field that allows him to
disrupt different forms of energy
creating havoc in both people and
machines he's also a martial arts expert
again there's no way to know until
Opening Day how faithful Terry Crews
portrayal will be to the comics only
that like his comic book counterpart
bedlam will be joining the ranks of
x-force who is shatter star if you think
cables origin story is convoluted wait
till you meet chatter star in the comics
shatter star is from a place called Mojo
world a planet that exists a century in
the future and is ruled by the
tyrannical villain mojo mojo world is
obsessed with entertainment and Shatter
star was a slave who was genetically
engineered to be a gladiator
he has enhanced strength and agility
heals faster than most is a master at
many different fighting styles can
channel shockwaves through weaponry and
can even open portals allowing people to
instantly teleport wherever they'd like
as far as its origin and Deadpool 2 is
concerned it's likely it will have
nothing to do with mojo world but
considering how much Deadpool made fun
of comic book movie tropes who knows we
could have a scene with cable bedlam and
shatter star all comparing dystopian
futures debating whose is worse Peter
and Hydra bomb who is Peter well the
short answer is that we don't know
there's some speculation that he's
Deadpool twos answer to longtime
Deadpool comics character Hyderabad
Hyderabad is on the surface a kind of
useless sidekick to Deadpool he's
cowardly bad at fighting and has
absolutely no special skills he's a
member of Hydra who will often cite
Hydra training Maxim's such as if I
can't see them they can't see me and
hiding behind each other he generally
responds to every situation by running
away the character actually had an
unofficial cameo in Deadpool
he's never referred to as Hydra Bob
because 20th Century Fox didn't have the
rights to that character but Deadpool
calls him Bob and they briefly talk
about working together in Jacksonville
he's among the only ones of Ajax
henchmen that Deadpool knocks
unconscious and doesn't kill please
I haven't seen you since Jacksonville
TGI Fridays it's possible that Fox
wanted a Hydra Bob for Deadpool too and
simply created their own schlub with a
different name because they didn't have
the rights not that Marvel Universe
though Deadpool is a Marvel Comics
character he doesn't live anywhere near
the mostly family-friendly Disney owned
Marvel Cinematic Universe though
Deadpool is not technically a mutant
he's one of the many Marvel characters
owned by 20th Century Fox as part of the
movie rights to the x-men's roster of
heroes and villains so Deadpool doesn't
have to worry about going up against
Thanos anytime soon even though both
characters are played by Josh Brolin
Disney is currently in the process of
buying and merging with Fox meaning that
actual crossovers will likely be
possible in the future but until then
Deadpool is most definitely banned from
Disney World
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]